sup doggies it's Wonder Mike here you
know your hip hop Maven music mogul
number one Expositor of all things cool
and fun and now well we have got a song
by NF it's called the search it has 201
million views I have never heard of the
search I had never heard of NF until on
the member block to the Michael Noel
show we covered let you down to actually
enjoy not a huge modern music fan but I
actually enjoyed the song so now we are
covering the search I will use all of my
powers of modern musical prowess to get
to the heart this very song this video
is brought to you by Black Rifle coffee
more from them in a moment for right now
let's get to
[Laughter]
[Music]
this guy does really elaborate music
videos I really like his cinematography
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey Nate how's life I don't know it's
all right I've been dealing with some
things like every human being and really
didn't sleep much last night I'm sorry
that's fine I just think I need a little
me time I just think I need a little
free time a little break from the shows
and the bus rides yeah last year I had a
breakdown thoughts telling me I'm lost
getting too loud had to see a therapist
and I found out something funny is going
on up in my house yeah I started
thinking maybe I should move out you
know pack my car take a new route clean
up my yard get the Noose out hang up my
heart let it air out air out I've been
searching what does that mean Nate I've
been learning grabbing my keepsakes
leaving my burdens while I brought a few
with me I'm not perfect looking at the
view Like This concerns me picking up
the cues right I'm quite nervous hate it
when I lose sight life gets blurry and
things might hurt me it's probably gonna
be a long journey but it's worth it
though Cold War out there kids grab your
coat spend a minute I know now I'm back
around looking for the antidote to crack
the cold
admittedly pretty given to me but I
can't condone [ __ ] down to me Imma
have to crack your nose for cracking
jokes I'm looking for the map to hope
you see that they're making a whole lot
of changes wrote a song about that you
should play it I get scared when I walk
on these stages I look at the crowd and
see so many faces yeah that's when I
start to get anxious that's what my
thoughts can be dangerous that's when I
put on my makeup and drowning
self-hatred forget what I'm saying
that's kind of weird because he just
landed on the only comment that I made
about it at the very beginning which is
that I really like the cinematography
and it feels like his videos are more
like movies even the music videos and
and that's what he's saying he had this
break he almost had a total mental
breakdown he went to see a psychiatrist
things seemed like they were going so
well but he felt like he was losing his
grip on reality and that is reflected in
the music the music is constantly moving
forward and it it feels almost like it's
accelerating it's keeping the meter but
just the the way that it plays you feel
this momentum coming he even calls your
attention to it he says the drums kick
in and now I'm just moving and I look at
and I see your faces so it's he's not
just whining and saying woe is me my
life is terrible but he's saying as
these things become more exciting I'm
I'm not be I'm not typical I'm having
this incredible rise my life is
Cinematic but as that's happening he is
losing his grip and he's losing his grip
on reality you see that where the The
beautiful landscape shot kind of cuts
out and it gets a little glitchy but as
he says from the beginning it's really
true for everybody Nate has life I don't
know it's all right I've been dealing
with some things like every human being
and really didn't sleep much last night
I just need a little more me time I just
need a little little free time so this
this is not just something where you
have to be a world famous rapper to
understand that it's true of everybody
especially once you get married
especially once you get a job especially
once you have kids you feel your time
slipping away you feel your your control
over circumstances slipping away that
might be particularly accentuated if
you're a big movie star but it's true of
everybody which I suspect is why this is
resonating Black Rifle coffee company is
helping you knock out your Christmas
shopping with a ton of phenomenal new
products this year shop the best Brewing
gear thermoses mugs and apparel designed
for folks who love our country and who
love coffee Black Rifle sources the most
exotic roasts from around the globe all
coffee is roasted here in the US by
veteran-led teams of coffee experts
stuff your Christmas stockings with the
latest roasts from America's coffee for
10 off with my code Knowles better yet
sign your Secret Santa up for a coffee
Club subscription imagine the joy of a
pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roasts when you need them most
it is the gift that keeps on giving
Black Rifle coffee company is veteran
founded and operated they take pride in
serving coffee and culture to people who
love America every purchase you make
with Black Rifle helps support veteran
and first responder causes go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code holes for
10 off coffee Coffee Gear apparel or
when you sign up for a new coffee Club
subscription that is black
riflecoffee.com promo code Knowles kwles
for 10 percent off okay keep going see
we've all got something that we trapped
inside that we try to suffocate you know
hoping it dies try to hold it under
water but it always survives and it
comes up out of nowhere like an evil
surprise then the hovers over you to
tell you millions of Lies you don't
relate to that must not be as crazy as
I'm the point of making is it's a
powerful place and what you feed it can
affect you in a powerful way it's pretty
cool right yeah but it's not what we say
just hang with me this will only take a
moment okay just think about it for a
second if you look at your face every
day when you get up and think you'll
never be great you'll never be great not
because you're not with the hate we'll
always find a way to cut you up and
murder your faith
irrelevant that dependency you measure
it take a measurement to back it up and
give me The Happening pretty evident
Dependable could never pretend it if I'm
a gentleman depending on if I think
you're genuine pretty elegant but not
afraid to tell you to get it can I keep
it to myself
when I slap your balloons and invite
your friends see bounce back on yeah
strap them in look at me
look at me smiling big
we tone that down but I can't resist
y'all know that sound better raise your
fist the search begins I'm back so enjoy
the trip
I'm very interesting to include cellos
in a rap song
[Music]
really interesting imagery here
trudging along like a bum with a
shopping cart with a balloon what's the
significance of the balloon
he is expressing in this visual way a
feeling that is
largely ineffable of the way that we go
through our lives especially as your
life begins to accelerate in its pace
and you've got all these
responsibilities and you're working very
hard and you've got a family and all the
rest of it you can feel like no matter
how hard you work you're just trudging
through the dirt and the mud and the
grass these tiny little rickety wheels
and you're just trying to push this
thing forward and then he's got the
balloons there and what do the balloons
represent well the balloons create this
kind of funny image in that you could if
they are helium balloons you would
expect the balloons to lift you up but
that's not what's happening he's just
pushing balloons are not lifting him up
he's not he he doesn't feel that levity
he's just kind of trudging on through
and so it's it's ironic it's a it's a
funny juxtaposition of those two things
and so the balloons are also a symbol of
childhood you know you go to the
carnival and you get a fun little
balloon or the doctor's office or
wherever but these aren't fun colorful
Blues these are dark balloons they're
the same color as the hoodie he's
wearing they're tied to his car at least
trying to push forward those memories of
childhood which have recurred and also
in the other song of his that that we
covered there and he says then it hovers
over you to tell you millions of Lies
you don't relate to that must not be as
crazy as I am and so he's saying what
you don't relate to that but of course
we do relate to that we've got these
ideas and these images and these desires
that we've cultivated for our whole
lives that just come back and they haunt
us and so I think that's what you're
seeing in this image and I think that's
why he's taking such a long break in the
song to just paint that image for you as
he's showing you in a way much better
than I can articulate in words or that
he can articulate in words that feeling
that he has that all of us have too
foreign
[Music]
sits down and closes up totally in his
own shell and then this sort of lab
hazmat suit wearing guy walks in
and puts the uniform there
why why does he put that uniform what is
the significance of the kind of lab coat
style well you see him allude to this
earlier on in the song he says where the
Biko
and he got a taste of Fame and they say
you have to pump my stomach a an
illusion I suspect to the way that when
people get famous they often get into
drug problems whenever any of us has uh
has a little too much hard living you
know has a little bit too much fun that
can spiral out of control and end up
causing us to damage ourselves and so
that the white clothing represents this
very clinical sterile uh view of the
world you think of the scientists in the
the laboratory and I think that's what
he keeps talking he says I just got to
keep going and I hear and the meat comes
on and I can't stop it and I've just got
to push forward and I've got to keep
trudging on ahead it's a very very
clinical way to live your life the thing
that the clinical people work on and the
thing that he directly alludes to are
these these drugs right he's got he's
had all these drugs he's got to pump my
stomach and so does that refer to also
what happens with so many musicians I
mean you think of Elvis Presley Elvis
Presley pill problem it was a big drug
it ended up contributing immensely to
his death but why was he taking the
drugs it wasn't just that funny so he
could keep working so he could keep up
with that Relentless Relentless Pace to
the point that when you reach the end
what is it you've crumpled in a ball
you've got you've got nothing left to
say you're in you're in the sort of
luggage of a homeless man collecting
garbage kind of a doer note to end on
but powerful song as far as modern music
goes pretty impressive you know it's not
modern music not always my cup of tea
but there's certainly a lot there from
Mr n f let me know what you think in the
comments we'll see you next time
foreign